great coaches great mentors great seals
if there's one thing they're very good
at they're very good at they have this
certain intuition where they know which
player talent or future leader to bet on
there's something about them they get
credit for choosing and putting their
money on the right people right so think
about it if there was a technology for
you to be able to tell how big Arnold
before Arnold became or know like a 14
years old what if we could figure out a
way to find out MJ before MJ's MJ what
if there was a way to figure out
Alexandre before Alexander the Great
became Alexander Reza Shah Pahlavi what
if there was a way to figure this I mean
this guy became he at 21 years old he's
given Iran this guy conquers the world
you know 2 million square miles of the
world can you really tell somebody
that's gonna be successful I'm here to
tell you there are seven signs there
you're going to be successful in life
and I've seen this from people that I
watched you were 18 years old not a
multi millionaires at 28 years old I saw
this where the kid that was 14 years old
9 26 years old multi multi-millionaire I
saw this with athletes young now they're
competitors doing very well for
themselves there are sides I'll share
seven of them here with you let's start
off with number one number one is
they're absolutely super competitive
let me explain super competitive it
doesn't matter what it is they have to
do it faster better bigger they just
have this one desire I'm gonna do it
better than you
and in the world of capitalism it's all
about competition the whole thing that
makes capitalism work is competition
what makes sports works is competition
these political people that think
they're better for you and I to vote for
the one that goes to the top is
typically the most competitive they want
to figure out a way to do better so
imagine we have a work environment we
have a work environment and there's a
first place person in any office in any
team in any basketball team even if the
team sucks there's somebody that's the
best on that team then he got a new cat
that comes in town and it comes into the
work work environment who goes into the
basketball team where it up whatever it
is this guy puts this guy's a target he
wants to beat him anything he does he
does diet work ethic time he comes on
everything because he is super
competitive and if he's out if he's
super compare
even more than them eventually passes
him up it's just simply how it is second
one they like to finish things let me
explain
they can play a puzzle right they can't
stop until they finish the puzzle they
play a video game they have to finish
the video game they have to finish it
they can't help themselves they got to
finish a video game you know they may be
reading a book they got to finish the
book there's a lot of people guys this
is a sign when I see people that only
read first chapter to chapter and then
they ask the question now what do you
think man I have like 30 books I've
started I haven't finished well there's
a sign
you don't like to finish things you like
things to be given to easy the people
that finish things they always finish
things they're gonna figure out a way to
finish things number three your circle
out earns you this is you this is your
circle they're bigger than you in life
in money in income in lifestyle you're
not you're the green one but if you if
you have a circle that out earns your
out succeeds you you're eventually going
to be there it's a formula this is not a
accidental thing this is why you'll
notice some of the people that don't
achieve success they always want people
smaller than them around them because it
makes them feel bigger the people that
you meet are super successful they
always put themselves on situations
where people are bigger than them
because it's the next platform next
level they're getting to next one their
mind never stops let me explain what I
mean by the mind never stops oh you know
what what if what if this happens and
what if what if I could have this life
what if I talk to this person what if I
go over here what if we could figure
this out they're embedding they're still
thinking you know what let me let me see
we should do this one no you know
earlier we were talking about this thing
three hours ago yes I was thinking about
it I think we need to do this this this
and what if we did this because this
could happen that their mind just never
stops like a beautiful mind
it never stops next credible people see
you going places
so how credible people credible people
view you let me explain let's just say I
meet John and John has a principal a
pastor the football coach the uncle and
a total different person that he worked
for out a company they all say this
guy's going places he's going places
he's going places if those five gave
their answers based on authentic real
answers this cat is going places why
because these five people pastor coach
boss teacher principal whatever these
five have spent endless hours with this
cat they know his flaws they know his
habits they know if he likes to finish
things they know if he out you know he
spent some time with people that are
ahead of him they know how competitive
they know that so if somebody says that
there's credibility they're so credible
people believe in you credible people
see you going places next one your
student it just they will not stop
learning
they can't stop learning they can't help
themselves they want to know this I want
to get better at this time want to get
better at this I want to get better at
that there's constant desire to want to
be a better student and learn more
that's number six and last but not least
they're extremely obsessive
they're extremely obsessive like I have
to have this let me explain it if you
were really able to dissect the mind of
an obsessive person it would concern a
lot of people because they would say
there's this person really think that
way they do they really do think that
way they really want what they want and
they really end up getting what they
want because they have to have it
they're obsessed about it and anytime
they're obsessed about it they start
figuring out creative ways to get what
they want if it's a girl if it's a
business if it's a position if it's a
certain success if it's accolades if
it's certain place they want to be if
it's a certain lifestyle they want
they're gonna figure out a way to get it
because they're obsessive they have to
have it they're just wired that way so
those are the seven signs where you and
I can tell if someone is going to be
successful or not see if you throw me
that pillow right there and and if you
watch this video here if you're telling
yourself man I got three out of the
seven well go share this with other
people see if they'll they'll validate
what you're thinking with 307 and if not
anything you're working you got five
people that are working with you and you
wonder which one for you to lock onto
you ask yourself out of these five
people you work with which one of them
has the most you pretty much be able to
tell which one of the guys is the person
that has a highest likelihood of one to
being successful I'm by the way there is
no hundred percent twenty of this it's
just odds
no one's ever going to be a hundred
percent there's a lot of smart people
that you know drafted to play then
better becoming nothing and they flopped
but you want to be eighty percent you
want to be seventy percent because if
you do this right majority time
eventually you're gonna put together
most incredible team in your business to
grow and go to different places now
having said that we want you to
subscribe to this channel we our goal as
a million subs click on the sub button
right here click on the alert right next
to be one the first to be alerted every
time we have a new video that's coming
out if you got any questions any
thoughts about what I just talked to
here in this video please comment on the
bottom thanks for watching everybody
take care bye bye
[Music]